[Music]
hello John by now you have received my
message that we will no longer be
communicating through any textual means
no more instant messaging no more
emailing only video blogging you can see
my eye in my eye okay just try to ignore
that there you can't see it now can you
last night I sent you an email from a
New Year's Eve party in Lake Tahoe the
email outlined our plans starting on
January 1st today I will send you a
video blog tomorrow you will reply to
that video blog we will continue like
this until the year is up if one of us
fails to send a video blog on a weekday
there will be certain punishments
Brotherhood 2.0 convinces today good
morning Hank is January 2nd 2007
I just spent 2 hours and 13 minutes
downloading your two men in one second
video which can mean only one thing
that I'm in mom and dad's house the last
residents in the United States of
America with dial-up internet on the
upside it's awfully pretty plus I get to
be surrounded by memories of our
childhood I know we've already agreed to
dole out punishments if one of us fails
to update our video blog on the
appointed date I've been thinking that
we could also periodically give each
other challenges I've come up with a few
suggested challenges the eat 5 sheets of
toilet paper while discussing the
political situation in Nepal challenge
I'm very interested in the political
situation in Nepal the drinking glasses
Strawberry Hill wine without hurling
challenge maybe we can make Thursdays
and Fridays challenge days hi John
good morning wow that guy was having fun
at seven o'clock in the morning and I'm
about to get on a plane
yesterday I was sledding down a hill
Lake Tahoe now it's fun this isn't fun I
hope you don't mind if I make a
suggestion as to how to begin our
conversation on this video blog being
your brother is kind of frustrating
sometimes this is because people walk up
to me and they say gosh you look so much
like your brother apparently some people
even think that we look like the twin
rock duo The Proclaimers which is
admittedly better than people thinking
that we look like a twin rock duo Nelson
so I would like to propose a list we
make a video blog list of all the ways
in which we are very very different
people things like in the last few years
John Green has gotten kind of pudgy
whereas in the next few years Hank green
will get kind of pudgy and also things
like John Green has never spilled a tiny
amount of beer on his life's in that
book which then proceeded to not boot up
and also John Green didn't do the happy
dance when his wife was in the shower
and he reinstalled the battery and tried
to boot it up the next morning and it
worked
good morning Hank it's Thursday January
4th I'm standing on top of little Pisgah
mountain in North Carolina Hank in your
last video you asked me to continue our
discussion of our differences I think
one of the most important differences
between us is that you are excellent at
living in a way that's commensurate with
your values whereas I not for instance I
didn't recycle until I watched
Inconvenient Truth but I'm still sort of
if he on it and also I didn't vote in
even though I could have voted in
Florida
ah George Bush it's all my fault I'm so
stupid
let's change the subject
also we have vastly different happy
dances yes well I noticed that in your
last video you completely ignored my eat
five sheets of toilet paper while
discussing the political situation in
Nepal challenge and if you're not going
to eat five sheets of toilet paper while
discussing the political situation in
Nepal well I'm going to well hum about
the political situation in Nepal and so
there are these malice rebels who can
hold more than half of the country who
has Maoist rebels anymore oh no I can't
do it Hank I think this stuff is two-ply
- I think that was a part of the problem
because you get the one-ply stuff I can
just swallow just down that but this
stuff move
good morning John it's January 5th and
I'm sitting in my basement back home
surrounded by all the things I love I
love orange juice
I love Mental Floss Magazine and
Benjamin Franklin I love that right
there there that's a map of the realm of
Narnia hold on I have to go upstairs and
get something what did I get
we don't actually have Strawberry Hill
here I didn't know with that I'd never
looked for it
Sutter home white zinfandel we'll have
to do a commenter suggested that I drink
a glass of Strawberry Hill wine and then
say eat five sheets of toilet paper
while discussing the political situation
in Nepal really fast without vomiting
I'm going to do that now there's only
one way that I'm going to be able to do
that and that's by getting corndogs
eating corndogs is the only way I can
chug an alcoholic beverage without
puking I don't know why I think maybe my
stomach's just like oh that corn dog is
so good I can't let go of it it's not
strawberry hill but it only costs three
dollars and sixty-five cents to
Brotherhood
if I shoot the toilet paper while
discussing the political situation in
Nepal here eat five sheets of toilet
paper while discussing the political
situation in Nepal